. David, I understand voting by mail, but
why should states accept ballots after Election
Day after all?
Election Day is Election Day.
Fair question.
Let's assume you're asking it in good faith.
The of the population that wants to vote should
be allowed to vote up until Election Day.
And if you want to vote absentee, you should
be allowed to do it.
So the only possible correct solution is as
long as your ballot has been sent by Election
Day.
It should count.
And in particular, when you think so, before
I go further, if the ballot has to be received
by Election Day, as is the rule in some states
and I disagree with it, you really only have
until if you assume it could take four days
for the ballot to be delivered.
You really only have until October 30th, the
thirty first to vote.
But Election Day is November 3rd.
Why should you be denied by four days when
you can send in your ballot?
If you are still able to do it before Election
Day, by Election Day, you should be allowed
to do it.
Now, on top of that, when you recognize the
way in which the Postal Service has been attacked
by Donald Trump's postmaster general, he now
says that he's not doing any more stuff.
Do we trust it?
Do we not?
There's just questions we don't want votes
to be able to be disqualified just because
the Postal Service delays the mail.
If the ballot is postmarked by November 3rd,
that is what should matter.
Now, if you want to be really cynical, the
post office could as they gather the ballots
on November 2nd and November 3rd.
Wait until November 4th and postmark them
then and get them disqualified that way.
We're now talking about a more sort of invasive
level of suppression.
But there is really no good reason for which
you should not have your vote counted as long
as you send it by Election Day.
We have a pandemic expecting more vote by
mail than ever.
We're already seeing it.
We've already seen by some reports more than
60 million votes already cast.
Could be close to half of the total electorate.
It's unbelievable numbers.
We want to make sure these votes are counted.
And if you vote by November 3rd, it should
be counted.
One last thought.
Not only are we going to see more vote by
mail than ever before.
We are going to see a lot of new voters voting
for the first time by mail.
Some mistakes are going to be made.
And I believe that we should as if we have
the goal not of being ticky tacky and figuring
out ways to disqualify ballots, which is what
Republicans want to do.
What I want to do is we should do everything
we can to get as many people as possible legally
voting.
We want time for people who make mistakes
on their ballots to be notified and to be
able to resubmit or decide to go in in person.
And I know that that will sound weird to a
lot of people who want to be very, very litigious
and regimented and strict father morality
sort of approach.
We believe that democracy is best served by
high voter participation.
And I do believe that then we should be doing
everything we can to get as many people to
successfully vote, period.
And if you believe that, you, of course, should
be allowing every vote to be counted, that
is postmarked by Election Day.